michel quand il ya des femmes voilées
excusez moi on n'est plus en france mais
pourquoi attendre des excuses moi alors
on va s'arrêter un instant nature oui
vous m'avez demandé ce que je ferai tout
et interdirait le voile partout et bien
dans la rue et dans tous les crédits est
ce que ça va changer ça va changer tout
simplement on se si vous voulez ces
visuels le voile qu'est ce que c'est c
est une volonté de coloniser le paysage
c'est donc qu'il pensait oui je le
promets je pense c'est un outil
politique mais vous savez le vêtement a
toujours été un outil politique ça a
toujours symbolisé on ne s'habille pas
par hasard quand les lélés les empereurs
japonais veulent moderniser leur pays au
19e siècle ils enlèvent leurs costumes
traditionnels ils se mettent en costume
comme nous n'en arriverons montrer la
modernité occidentale donc le vêtement
est un est une arme politique donc j'ai
interdirait le voile pour l'instant
j'arrive encore une fois ce qui me pose
problème dans notre logiciel c'est ce
manque de discernement en fait vous
essentialiser tout vous protégez vous
prenez sujet le voile avec une forme de
commissions politiques et autres ça peut
exister réellement une femme qui portera
le val sous la contrainte ça peut
exister mais si je vous dis a contrario
que l'immense majorité des femmes qui
portent le foulard le font par
conviction en respectant les principes
de laïcité avec une fois qu'ils étaient
intérieur comme les soeurs catholiques
comme les soeurs juive et moi je suis
pour que l'animal ait de quoi tient dans
notre pays pas excusez moi la liberté de
conscience dans notre pays soit
respectée hérité bon ensuite nous avons
des règles dans les services publics
ceux qui sont détenteurs du message du
spin-off pas avoir de signes
ostentatoires c'est très bien à l'école
on ne peut pas porter le cran c'est très
bien mais là vous n'êtes pas laïque fait
même pas du laïcisme c'est une forme
d'obsession contre les musulmans
auraient dû tout le monde je vous dirais
du tout mais ces derniers mois de
contrat du mérite pas du tout et ça le
sujet alors que tout jeudi la répression
qui s'abat face à chelsea je suis contre
tout signe religieux même pour les juifs
et les quartiers c'est à dire que les
soeurs catholiques ne pourront pas s pas
les professionnels mais c'est quoi dans
la région mena ya des professionnels
dire oui à oullins michael jarrell les
curés sont donnés les rebelles n'ont pas
du tout pas ici
bal à la liberté de conscience ne nie
pas des professionnels ou des amateurs
le prêtre le prêtre oui non je suis en
l2 largeur catholique euros s'ils
portent le foulard sort aussi c'est un
bas au conditionnel monsieur zeribi new
line cardinet nom ne fait pas son nom
non non non non c'est vous dire finir le
fait patienter vous a fait semblant le
dévoile pour dwan de la solennelle le
voile islamique je suis désolé ce n'est
aps le contraire de la laïcité la
laïcité c'est le devoir de discrétion
l'espace tout mais pas du tout je suis à
l'insolite et celle alignée journée
comme ça re croire ou de ne pas croire
il y à des lieux au sein desquels on ne
porte pas de signes religieux riggs et
mot et c'est très bien et en tant que ça
si fier de l'être aimé mon pays et ses
valeurs et ses principes je me battrai
jusqu'au bout pour que ce soir ils vous
aimez moi un pays où si je vous ai relu
mon travail ne pouvait pas tolérer le
vent espagnol a contrario on termine
carrément remonter fruits parce que sa
ligne a dépassé femme modeste qui
portent parce qu'elles ont une
conviction religieuse
les kilomètres opéré sans modestie
respectent la république mais la laïcité
vous voulez faire intrusion ne restent
fidèles à la france je vous dire ce soir
moi je n'ai jamais dit que j'étais de
confession musulmane sur aucun plateau
mais tout marc journée je considère que
c'est du ressort de la vie privée mais
là je ne défends pas le voile qu'on ne
se trompe pas je défends la liberté de
conscience non pas du tout c'est hubert
de service à laquelle vous portez
atteinte et moi je vous le dit eric
zemmour je vous le dis et je vous le dis
vraiment presque amicalement même si je
ne pourrais pas être votre ami commun
eric naulleau parce qu'on est aux
antipodes sur le plan des valeurs et
donnez moi monsieur zeribi les élus
lillois de phrases et rim gérante de
brens monsieur eric yeux il n'y a pas
d'incident n'est pas de liberté avec le
jeu un jeu vers le l'islam ne connaît
pas la langue de 10 ans ahmed mera
l'islam ne connaît pas la liberté et
glam veut dire sous series et vous
voulez voir les tarifs et donc c'est
tout notre problème c'est que justement
l'islam se sert des libertés française
pour
s'introduire dans l'espace public et
river man s'est exercée c'est tout le
problème foncier non combien de
militaires nous avons dans notre pays
deux forces armées des thèmes bien
apprise échelle vous devez le savoir
premier entre 100 et 200 milles non on
en à 270 milles on voyait un peu votre
copie c'est important parce que la
défense
alors bien sûr les deux cent soixante et
dix mille militaires professionnels à
nos forces armées qui sont sur des
théâtres d'opérations qui donnent leur
vie on a 20 % de musulmans et à l'anti
rides mais monsieur zemmour je peux
terminer j'ai dit dans mon dos qui a
ordonné un je peux faire mieux je me
sentais la main pour musulman je te
conseil musulman je peux terminer pas de
problème avec ça que d'arrêter après
karim sait finir 100% mais je vous
invite à lire un papier du new york
times qui parle de ces mêmes % et qui
parle de la manière dont l'armée
française considère respecte au nom de
la laïcité ils ont des repas de
substitution dans l'armée française si
l'on isole des aumôniers l'armée
française comme il ya des aumôniers
juifs et catholiques en fait ce que je
veux vous dire qu'un drapeau sécurisé
mois qu'elle rappelle le rapport c'est
l'égalité de traitement et oui le
rapport ces jeunes avaient par exemple
été noués sur une frange de la
population mais le rapport c'est de
distinguer les islamistes des musulmans
monsieur ce que vous ne faites pas c'est
ça le rend très régulièrement monsieur
il est fondamental conclut et concluait
régler la facture et clément l'un sur la
libérer car c'est très simple merci car
monsieur zeribi parle sans cesse de
laïcité et le moment il ne nous plaisent
et ce sont des principes la laïcité
c'est le devoir de discrétion dans la
rue ce n'est pas seulement la ruine et
oui merci